Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Thank you for tuning in.
Today's topic is reactivating a language
that you haven't used in a long time.
A lot of colleague lights and a lot of
language and fuzziest.
They'll say things like ice be 15
languages or I speak 20 languages or you
make your 30 or 40 or crazy numbers like
that,
and that can be really intimidating
because most of us think I could never
learn that many languages.
I'm just a normal person.
I don't have that much talent.
But what most of those people are saying
is that they have learned that many
languages well during their lifetime.
They usually can't switch between all of
those languages whenever they want
without taking some time to reactivate
the language and kind of get back into
it.
So they kind of need some preparation
time before they can speak that language
again.
Now most people usually have some
languages that are kind of in the front
of their brand,
their active languages that can switch
between them.
I think that's usually like three or
four languages.
I think it depends on the person and how
often they use all of those in their
life.
But in my experience it's three or four.
And in my observation of other people,
it seems to be three or four the other
languages aside from that kind of recede
into the background and they'd become
dormant.
And in order to use those languages you
have to reactivate them,
get back into them.
So if somebody said to me right now,
okay,
you're going to Israel tomorrow,
you have to be able to speak Hebrew
tomorrow,
I would kind of panic because I haven't
spoken Hebrew in about 12 years.
So it would take me a few days,
it would take me a week to take me a
couple of weeks to get back into Hebrew
to the point where I was confident
speaking it,
even though I would say that 12 years
ago I was conversationally fluent in
Hebrew and I could read it pretty well
too.
I would still need some time to refresh
my,
my language skills and get back into
things because it's receded into the
background for sure.
So how do you reactivate a language like
that that's become dormant?
Well,
you basically need to just dive right
back into it and see where your
weaknesses lie and see what you can do
and see what you can to do.
And the best way to do that is by
interacting with someone and using the
language communicatively.
Now,
recently I did that at work.
I realized that one of my coworkers is a
native Hebrew speaker,
so I tried having a conversation with
him and Hebrew and I could do it kind
of,
but I realized that a lot of things that
slipped my mind and I wasn't nearly at
the level that I was 12 years ago,
which is to be expected.
I wasn't surprised.
I was actually surprised by how well I
could speak Hebrew who had this point
after 12 years of dormancy.
But uh,
that experience was important because it
showed me,
okay,
these are the things I'm forgetting.
These are the things that are not such a
problem.
The things that are usually the first to
slip and go away.
When the language becomes dormant is the
vocabulary.
Vocabulary goes away really quickly and
sometimes it's even really basic
vocabulary.
You know,
things like apple,
things like car words like sleep and
stuff like that often will just
disappear from your,
from your memory and it's in there
passively.
Usually usually your passive skills will
kind of remain intact and when you hear
those words you'll understand them,
but when it's time to speak,
they won't come up.
I would say that that's definitely true
for vocabulary and to some extent also
for verb conjugations in my experience,
but in my experience it's not that way
for syntax or word order.
I don't really have any trouble building
Hebrew sentences or making sentences in
the language.
It's mostly a problem of vocabulary and
to some extent the verb conjugations.
Usually there's also a kind of lack of
fluency and it takes you longer to get
the sentences out.
I don't think that's a problem with the
grammar or sentence structure though.
I think that's typically a problem with
vocabulary because you have these ideas
you want to express,
but you don't know how to bring up the
words to express those ideas.
So you slow yourself down in order to
retrieve those words and look for the
vocabulary to express what you want to
say.
And sometimes you end up paraphrasing or
explaining it in a different way and
that just slows down your fluency.
I don't think it's a problem with her
sentence structure.
To me in my experience,
that's usually something that sticks
longterm.
Now assuming that you learned the
language quite well the first time
around,
and by well I mean conversationally
fluent,
then it's basically a matter of
refamiliarizing yourself with those
things that you've forgotten so that
they can become active instead of
passive so that you can use them
productively.
You can speak using those elements and
you can write using those elements,
not just understand them when you
encountered them.
Sell the two steps of that are
encountering those language elements
passively with books or with videos and
audio and then giving yourself a chance
to use it.
So I have some old Hebrew materials that
are used to use back in the day that I
can use to refamiliarize myself
passively with some of these language
elements.
So I have this one Hebrew in three
months.
This one I think is out of print,
but I really liked these in three months
series by you go,
they're all really good if you could
find them online.
But this is the Hebrew one.
Let me look at a sentence and just see
if it reminds me of things that I've
forgotten.
Uh,
it says here on this page and Neil
Patella hood's a nickel,
a chef shunted sally flatwoods.
Key.
O'Neil have Leo or backwards.
Uh,
so that means he's talking about a
marathon and he says,
I want to run and I think I need to run
because I love being outside.
Okay.
Uh,
probably that's all familiar to me.
I wouldn't have forgotten any of those
words.
The next sentence,
uh,
a of Albert holds up.
We laid low [inaudible] the Shabbat.
Okay.
So he says,
but on the other hand when he says,
but in any case,
maybe I shouldn't because I had a cold
on Saturday,
so the word [inaudible] which means in
any case,
I don't think I would've remembered that
unless I saw it written right here.
But now it's coming back to me just
seeing it once and also the word
Nazella,
that means like a cold.
I haven't thought of that word in 12
plus years,
so I wouldn't have been able to pull
that word up out of my memory and
produce it.
But now that I've seen it,
I'm starting to remember cases when I
used this word back in the day.
So I think this is already being
refreshed in my memory and I'll be able
to use those words in the near future.
Another book I used is this one
mastering Hebrew,
which is actually one of the FSI books,
the free public domain ones that you can
get for free on the Internet in pdf
form.
But the Hebrew one's good.
Let me look at something in this.
Let's see.
Uh,
he says there's a shot,
a middleware,
the ls there,
Shiva,
the Shiva is,
and look dumb again.
And he'd say [inaudible] and they'll
have the book.
Okay.
So he says,
at what time do you get up?
And the other guy says around seven and
the first guy says,
it's seven.
That's early in.
The second guy says,
yes,
I need to make breakfast for my family.
So I'm most of those words,
we're still kind of familiar to mix.
They're quite basic,
but the word mittal hour to get up,
I don't think I would have been able to
remember that.
And now that I'm thinking about that
word,
I'm remembering other related works like
shown malware shut on mail order that
that's like an alarm clock,
a clock that wakes you up.
So I'm remembering related words and
it's kind of becoming like a web.
Like I remember one word.
Then I remember related words and other
things.
And now I'm thinking of some sentences
with that word that I made a long time
ago.
So it all comes back when you just start
to refamiliarize yourself with some
things that have become dormant.
So those are two textbooks that I've
used in the past.
I also like to use phrase books like
this.
This is the lonely planet Hebrew phrase
book.
These ones are quite good.
I like the lonely planet.
His books,
they're good to just flip through and
just read simple sentences,
read simple phrases,
and just review basic vocabulary because
most of the vocabulary in here,
his daily life vocabulary,
it's quite practical.
So it's good.
It's a good way to just to get that core
vocabulary back into your,
your active vocabulary.
So if I just opened to a random page,
let's see if I can do it.
It says,
okay,
uh,
[inaudible] uh,
can you write this down please?
A Little Sean?
I don't know if I would have remembered
the word Leo Sharm without seeing it
right here.
So,
uh,
I probably would have said like half
Shah [inaudible] is it possible to rate
this?
I probably would have said let's solve
instead of real sean.
But when you're writing something down,
like on a list,
you just show them is the better word to
use.
So it's good that aside here,
another example,
let's see.
Um,
[inaudible] at the bank.
Ah,
okay.
When do they open the bank?
When does the bank open?
Probably those words are okay.
I would have remembered those materials
when [inaudible] comes from pat
documents to open.
So I would've remembered these words,
I think.
But let's see if Shar Lao viola guns
[inaudible] uh,
can I transfer money here from my bank?
So that one,
I think I would've remembered most of
those words except Leah via,
which is to transfer.
Um,
but now that I've seen it,
I'm remembering a speech that they saw
by Benjamin Netanyahu on tv like 12
years ago where he said something like,
uh,
good luck.
Bye.
[inaudible] new [inaudible]. [inaudible]
means like,
uh,
this is his Zionist philosophy you said
on there by bringing all the vast
majority of Jews to Israel,
can we fulfill the dream of Zionism?
So she was saying bring,
he said they hired via ems to transfer
them here.
So I just remembered that after seeing
the word in this,
this phrase book right now.
So that's the kind of thing you can do.
It just refamiliarize yourself with
those language elements.
And then you start to connect them with
other elements that you've learned with
other situations.
You've used the men,
and then you start to get that snowball
effect.
So that's one of the things you can do.
Also,
in recent months with Hebrew,
I've been watching some,
some youtube videos in Hebrew.
Uh,
that wasn't planned.
It was just that I stumbled upon some
interesting videos.
There were street interviews done partly
and Hebrew.
So listening to the Hebrew passively
reminded me of some of those language
elements.
So remember it a lot of vocabulary and
it improved my listening skills again,
but that's,
I'll just riff familiarization.
It's also important to produce the
language,
right?
So I'm going to take some Hebrew lessons
to get back into producing Hebrew
verbally and we'll see how it goes.
I'll probably just start practicing
those elements that I've been reviewing
and all of these books.
But sit,
uh,
Num Sheer Laguna Bezalel Oh,
I'd see lockers or legal claims.
Uh,
I need any hot say,
let's say l there's metal at the palm of
our last shelf money and this amount.
[inaudible].
So basically in conclusion,
I just want to say don't feel that you
have some kind of pressure to learn to
be fluent in multiple languages and to
always be able to speak them all the
time.
Most people who are language and
fuzziest are polyglots there can't do
that.
They need to actually prioritize certain
languages.
Those are usually the ones that they're
currently using,
the ones that are currently relevant to
their life.
They're focused on using those ones and
keeping them active.
And the other ones they have learned in
the past received them become dormant.
But that's okay because if you ever need
them,
you just need a bit of notice and then
you can reactivate them by re
familiarizing yourself with some of the
things that have slipped out of your
memory and then producing them so you
can get them back into your active
language ability.
So don't sweat it.
Don't feel any kind of pressure.
Don't take on some kind of ego identity.
Like,
I need to speak all these languages
because I'm a polyglot or whatever.
It.
Don't do that to yourself.
Just relax and have fun.
Enjoy the languages.
No,
that there will always be there.
Especially if you've learned the
language quite well,
then it will always be there.
You just need to re activate it,
so don't even worry about it.
All right,
this is Paul.
Thank you for watching.
Have a good nights.
When you're an infant,
you spend about a year just sitting
there listening to the language before
you actually see anything.
Just absorbing the salads.
You're internalizing the phonology
before you actually produce it as an
adult that you have a year to sit around
doing that.
I know I don't.
So I've been talking about focusing the
grand sense,
like in terms of your large goals and
that kind of thing,
but of course the focus is also
important in the moment because we live
in such a distraction prong world.